yes when we welcome to another episode
of tiger belly I'm your captain Bobbie
Lee
we've got kalila we got Gilbert we got
Georgetown pink dick USA Hollywood
Knights what's up dog all day dog urban
urban bobbies here and I am very excited
today because we have a very special
guest now
I did a movie years ago excuse me I'm
not laughing I'm happy oh because I
think it's the most underrated
overlooked movie of all time I think
it's up there with Forrest Gump
Godfather two movie was called kickin it
old-school and it was with the white to
share my foon Jamie Kennedy and we and
the guy that played the evil villain in
the movie Michael Rosenbaum you brought
Michael Rosen was the first before we're
so light but that one was deep and angry
yeah you have yeah you fought a lot I do
for it a lot don't understand why my
most of mine don't smell yet they don't
say I don't like Rosenbaum honestly I'd
kill you as a friend I'd murder you if
your fart smoke is you fart so often
yeah but maybe because it's you never
hold it that it actually never develops
a sense that's a great theory if you
hold it the air inside your body gets
mixed in with the [ __ ] well hey that's
why it's not a theme shoot you might be
yeah no I don't he does all daily do not
possibly do not fart the other night
like three weeks ago the other night
when you were in the bathroom remember
we brought it up okay I was in the
bathroom god forbid that's where people
usually fart Bobby
and also I know I mentioned this in the
other podcast I think last week or the
week before she didn't flush the toilet
so I saw one of her sheds on my toilet
it wasn't it was it was been it had been
there for so long that it broke apart
you know you know me so now you have
like it's like a sea of [ __ ] like
asteroids like asteroids it look like
the Philippines Peleg oh yeah rosie was
telling me that he his ex he didn't say
the movie that we did kicking it old
school
oh you did with Jamie Kennedy and Maria
Menounos you know and that other guy was
a black guys name Oh what was his name
Miguel new nose yes not McGill new nose
right I ran into him at the airport once
and he barely said hello to me I think
you said one time on set man I'm never
doing another Jamie Kennedy movie Miguel
Nunez said oh can I say also on that set
yes and correct me if I'm wrong but I
think I went into my dressing room and
you had you were in there my own
dressing room
you were completely naked and you were
Lingus your liddie against the wall of
the trailer trailer and I go hi hello
and he just left
yeah but like I didn't really know him
that well but I am they just say this
too in terms of I'm Hollywood dicks I've
seen on I've seen I've seen them all who
have you seen Pauly Shore Chris D'Elia
they're both very big dicks yours is
probably the biggest wait wait but can I
just say something has a girl I have
ever said when they poked up with you
yes oh you're a big they said that that
sound does look at me right but haven't
they said it to you no come on I think
all girls say that to guys like oh my
god this have you ever have you ever
said that to me about my dick
I mean I might have like embellished
yeah yeah she said once you don't seem
like you should have a dick that big oh
that's that's good that's not good any
further next thing to a [ __ ] like if
you hook up with a major in your dick is
pretty bigger than a [ __ ] no but small
in terms of average you maybe shave down
there now we want to get lost in Joe
Cocker yeah make it look bigger so you
trim the hedges and everything just you
know yeah it's also perfectly shaped
pianist oh thank you how closely did you
look at it Bobby Jesus I have pictures
of him naked Oh usually it's like
blackmail for most actors you better get
me work by the way you were on this show
that I just saw about the hot sauce oh
yeah yeah and so thanks I can go on
there because I wanted to [ __ ] my pants
no but that's how you and I opened our
communication because we didn't talk to
each other about a year yeah and you've
texted me I thought you were very funny
on that and kind I want to say this
about Michael Rosenbaum Paul so that's
going to his little excursion he was in
11 year 10 years on Smallville 7 years
but I felt like 10 I did okay and then
you're also on a show called on pastor
that you're the leader and pastor and
you're really you're a really good dude
but can I just say this is that you
you're one of those guys in LA that help
people I really believe that because I
know for your show on pastor that you
brought me and I really appreciate it
and when people do that when your
friends do that in this business they
bring you them and they try to help you
it really is it gives you hope that this
town isn't just full of insects and
[ __ ] cockroaches I know but there are
little lights and he's a light you know
that's very kind of you I think it's
important I mean it's your upbringing
right would it mean maybe it's not my
parents sucked
yeah it was you know I just have a loyal
group of friends they usually if I like
someone I'm Mike and they're talented
you know
we help them oh that's an if you if you
can do something why wouldn't you do
something like cuz you know a lot of
people when they get you got me on this
podcast you're able to I said no no but
I but you I'm using you sure yeah I said
Michael Rosenbaum I mean that we Waldo
we're like any wise or a rabbi in this
way
[Music]